what do we think about whatever think
the impact of the 2019 class is gonna be
interest that doesn't seem like a great
business I don't knows mates doesn't
seem like a great business yeah yeah you
got a respect to put a little post mates
just cuz I think they've just just
scrapped their way surviving is I mean
they've done successfully I'm it's a
wonderful story about a team I mean I
think the underappreciated
aspect of all of this is that there have
already been a bunch of secondaries
right I have friends who have bought
city blocks who were Ober employees so I
think it's overstated maybe we'll see
but I think people don't appreciate the
the extent to which money is already
coming into the economy so we talked
about the housing boom yeah folks are
already buying houses it was the early
employees for there to be some impact
from these things but not the not the
sort of the classic Apple story where
the day after the IPO right everybody's
driving for you're not gonna have a fat
issue because the secondary markets
super robust I mean I just I'm getting
emails every day about Robin Hood and
calm and just everybody looks at a three
year old four year old company Robin
Hood
I don't yeah I guess I know many of
these companies now annually they
organize secondary sales go to LPS who
want to buy in organize a secondary the
money comes in and they just buy out
employees for SpaceX does every six
months my understanding is II long it's
a list of like who wants to sell and
they can sell like a little bit he just
approves it and then you know stay stay
private longer seems to have been a good
idea do we think it's a good idea I mean
yes but I'm gonna put an asterisk on
that I want to ask them maybe a
potentially really dumb question you do
that with enough frequency and with
enough capital and the company is doing
well enough
aren't you just creating a system by
which you're showing the exit door to
all of your team your best people like I
actually think about it the other way I
think actually uber made this mistake
where they had a bunch of people who
hated their jobs oh yeah definitely
don't want to like you can't cut people
it's toxic
right if somebody I think that if your
way of keeping people at the company is
you you can't afford to leave
because you can't buy your options it's
very different than saying I'm gonna top
you up on new options to motivate you
yeah but I think ultimately if you're
not motivating your people by making it
a place they want to show up and work so
just you're doing the wrong thing and
you get dysfunctional real quick yeah I
mean I think that was a real problem for
uber yeah Thank You Lee I'm just having
you know friends who have gone through
that mill and you know they're like I
hate it but I can't leave I can't afford
to buy my office solutions pretty easy
just giving people a year or two years
or three years to execute their options
yeah so we give people the number of
years they've been with the company
after one year so if you've been with
the company for a year maybe you get a
year if you've been with the company for
less than a year right so and then we
capped that at five years so at five
years you guys did you come up with that
are your attorneys or is that came up
with you came up with yes okay so for
people who don't understand when you
leave a company you have options in the
company you have to pay to buy them you
have to execute them when you leave the
company you have 30 days typically and
you get a big tax bill and you come out
of pocket so somebody leaving an uber
and airbnb we could be talking about
millions of dollars for them to execute
those options which they then can't
trade cuz they're not public yet right
so you're paying for something that's
illiquid and if you were at one of these
companies should probably didn't have a
bunch of cash to because well you
probably went there well and if you're
an uber I mean you probably know that
that stocks gonna be worth something but
I can't tell you how many people I know
who bought options in something that
went to zero yeah so I mean employees
are paying paying these companies when
they leave after getting a crappy salary
for years and it's just broken it's dark
you've kind of alluded to the tax
problem I mean there's a legal fix to
this the real solution because you can
you can allow somebody to execute for
five years but they then don't get the
tax advantage so it's not yeah what
partially flips over right you get an ie
you get is Oh standing I think for like
a year and then it flips over to NSO
which has other tax implications and
there's nothing we can do about that
shadow equity programs to people who are
doing now like when you are not a
venture I guess when you're a zebra but
you're a company that doesn't have
intentions of being a unicorn in the
zebra movement
I guess people do shadow equity if
you're at the company at the time it
sells the founder is gonna put 20% on
the side and just chop it up amongst the
employees as a bonus and you have to go
through all this legal work I don't know
if you guys have seen that I haven't
done that you've done it yeah yeah Jay
did that when we sold Goucher oh did you
really yeah that would be that we caught
we carved out well so we were we were
given basically a pool of money to
decide what we wanted to do with it we
could keep as much of it for ourselves
Peter and I as we wanted we carved out I
think it was like 20% for the team